the man the moment he's done it all and
won it all
Olympic champion marathon world record
holder but becoming the first person to
run the distance in under two hours has
eluded Elliot Kip chogi until now the
official marathon distance of forty two
point two kilometers has a 100-year
history Kip Cho he was aiming to do what
many had thought impossible the flat
course was designed to assist a fast
time Vienna in autumn specifically
chosen for optimal conditions and Kip
togi was aided by a team of 41
pacemakers laser technology helped guide
the runners to maintain the
record-breaking pace as the clock
reached 159 the crowds watched on as one
of the great barriers of distance
running was taken apart and kicked oh
geez already legendary status reached
even greater heights
[Applause]
after a Japan's the mystery in 1954 we
took another substitute the 63s
I tried and I'd not get I know it's the
sixth area
I have tried I'm happiest man to run
under to us you know that to inspire
many people he is genuinely I think his
modesty really is something that maybe
doesn't catapult him to ultra super
stardom in the sporting world but he is
the Leo Messi of running essentially he
is the Roger Federer of athletics he is
the greatest distance running talent
we've probably ever seen this board this
was classed as a solo race and the level
of assistance Kip shogi received all
mean as this won't count as an official
world record but this wasn't about
records this was about the realization
of a lifetime ambition Lauren Smith
al-jazeera